de la chanson française.
Nabi-Alexandre Chartier
- Barbara, Bécaud, Trenet ou
Piaf, pour son 27e album
studio, Julien Clerc revisitepls
grandes chansons françaises,
des pièces comme la chanson
de Léo Ferré Comme à
♪ Ni gris ni verts ♪
♪ Comme àenenenende ♪
JULIEN CLERC, chanteur
- J'ai gardéun spectacle de Léoe
j'avais vu à l'Olympia....
Vous sortiez de là, plutôt que
sur un petit nuage et heureux,l,
vraiment aux tréfonds
de vous-même. Comme à Ostende
m'avait absolument bouleversé.
Il faut que je reprenne ça,papat
partie des choses qui m'ont
marqué
même qui m'ont donné
envie de faire ce méti
un monument de la chanson.
Au cous s s s s cinq décennies
de carrière, il a eu l'occasion
de côtoyer ces grrrrrrrrrrrrrrr.
♪ Que vais-je faire ♪
- J'ai eu la chance de pouvoir
les rencontrer, souvent même
des duos avec pratiquement
tous csososososont là, dans
des émissions de télévision.
Il y en avait évidemonononononos
bien. Mais j'ai fait,
par exemple, la première partie
de Bécaud des dizaines
♪ On était tous amoureux
d'elle ♪
♪ On se sentait pousser
♪ À bicyclette ♪
- Des pièces qu'il reprend
et si particulière.IlIlIlIlIlIle
une légende quand il arrivait,
un tra
un tour de chant absolument
au point dans lequel i
C'était un des rares quand même
à danser comme ça dans
C'est resté pour moi aussi...
Là, ça, c'est un des spectacles
gravé dans mon coeur.JuJuJuJuJus
beaux textes du répertoire
l'empêche pas d'être inspiré
par des créateurs contemporains.
Sur son disque précédent,
Terrien, paru en 2020, il a
collaboré avec plusieurs jeunes
paroliers comme Clara Luciani.
- Dieu merci, la chanson
francophone existe toujours
ieieieieieieien et il y a encore
des gens vraiment qui écrivent
des beaux textes dans la langue
française. Donc, évidemment,
je me tourne maintenan
vers des gens plus jeunes,
ce qui est normal.
- Julien Clerc sera
de retour au Québec cet automne
pour une tournée d'une quinzaine
de dates qui l'amènera
aux quatre coins de la province.
Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier,
a,a,a,a,a,a,a,a, Montréal.
♪ Qui résonnent
et c'est très bien ♪